foreign
Karma their Tick Tock accounts is just
full of
wonderful things so this one came up uh
and I was like oh that's that's a
fascinating take so John you're gonna
you're gonna just get right now Han
that's that's next oh okay okay here's
the video first yeah okay let's do this
one thing that's cool about becoming an
adult is that it's very embarrassing to
not have a credit card do you have a
credit card Channing
[Music]
first of all you have to understand what
a credit card is Alexa can you explain
to me what a credit card is all I know
is that you swipe and get free money
then you need to know how to use it to
your benefit Megan what perks do you get
from your credit card I think I get like
airline miles or something maybe like a
trip to Mexico and then you need to
figure out which one to apply for credit
karma is the secret life hack everyone
needs in their life to make things a
little easier than searching for a new
credit card you can explore different
kinds of cards and the best part is that
you can see your chances of approval
before even applying but won't it hurt
your credit to look on Credit Karma nope
and it's free so if you want to make the
most informed decision before applying
for a credit card go check out Credit
Karma you won't be disappointed
hey can I just ask you something when
you're hanging out because like I've
just been with a lot of like a lot of
rooms with guys just hanging out doing
stuff oh yeah have you ever
like do you and your friends get
together do you all like say the same
thing together
when one of your friends is knitting do
you all go hey you want to stay at the
same time yeah the only time I say the
same phrase if someone is George
Campbell these days and this is smart
money happy hour we say that at the same
time that's about that's the closest in
unison I get uh so
so let's we'll we'll talk about it in a
second that's gross but what's fun that
was just gives me the Ooze I'll get you
just like
uh we're never just shaming it's like I
know if you don't want to be the loser
you don't want to yeah if you don't have
a credit card because there's a level of
like that of that social
tribal right idea that's like I want to
plug in and when you're on the outs
we're gonna just smug and but you're it
literally kicks brain chemistry in
action to get you back into your tribe
right and so videos like that are are
not not only are they deceptive and
they're like not cool but they have
actual physiological chemical like
responses in people's bodies they're
like oh I don't know I don't want my
friends
what am I doing what am I doing wrong
yeah so one of their big selling points
though in that Tick Tock video
specifically was that you can get
pre-approved like you can know if you're
pre-approved before you ask actually
apply for a credit card so now they're
actually being sued Credit Karma by the
FTC FTC uh because they are falsely
pre-approving people for credit cards so
the same thing that they're like
encouraging being like Oh yeah we can do
this
they're being sued for so man
God bless God bless credit card
companies just trying to get you people
in the afternoon most complaint
allegeset from these dates to these
dates Credit Karma falsely told many
consumers they had been pre-approved for
credit offers
leading consumers to apply incur a hard
inquiry in the credit reports and if
they're denied potentially damage their
credit scores unnecessarily that part I
don't even care about like I mean I I
don't like it they're lying to their
potential customers
um and they're hurting their credit
reports I just I I that's more Insidious
because kids live on Tick Tock and it's
propaganda
yeah well and it's like the sarcasm a
little bit behind it of like so do you
know what it is I don't know I think
it's just like free money and it's like
showing this like uneducate what feels
uneducated I know they're just trying to
be snarky about it but that snarky is
it's just free money or you just get
free airline miles yeah like oh that's
what a credit card it's been to like the
idea and it's like oh I'm learning
something yeah through this tick-talking
gross